hello room hi everyone thanks for coming
I remember you would occur I am really
excited to be here I've already learned
so much this weekend and I'm excited to
be able to hopefully impart a little
lessons learned from my little corner of
the universe to if you can't hear me at
any point please just raise your hand
and tell me to pump up the volume
because I know that I can talk quietly
sometimes try to keep the mic really
really close to my mouth good I'm gonna
talk about data dashboards made from
open data and Python web scraping using
Python for that purpose and actually I
think I'm really fortunate to have
followed our keynote speakers this
morning because my talk is going to be a
little bit of an extension of Starr's
talk about making open data more usable
for people and making it more of a
public utility and then a little bit
from the earlier speakers talk about I
really like that slide with a percentage
breakdown of data analysis versus
storytelling because in my job I have to
do all of those things because there's
only one of me that's doing data work
actually too now we've just hired
someone but I work in the government so
data science data science is not
something that typically has been a
focus of hiring so that's my context a
bit more about me I studied economics so
that's the background I come from that's
really the data that I'm most familiar
with I didn't really have a lick of
experience coding and all with anything
but Stata about a year and a half ago so
I'm kind of new to Python new to
everything here but I've been working
with economic data for a long time
macro data broad indicators survey data
financial institution data using census
American Community Survey data and I
used to work at the CFPB trying to put
together data resources to monitor risks
in the mortgage market so that we could
avoid the government kind of
caught blindsided by what happened a
decade ago in the housing bubble burst
and now I work for the DC government in
the office of the deputy mayor for
planning and economic development which
fortunately has an acronym because that
is too many syllables to say on a
regular basis it's dump ed right up here
and what we do there or what I do there
is I monitor the economy of DC for
warning signs and for like looking at
good stuff like wonder what can we be
proud of in our city too so using open
data and other data sources to kind of
build a narrative of what's going on and
do you see economically so all that is
to say I'll go back you're right all
that is to say that that's kind of the
the use case that I have but I I think
that what I'm going to talk about here
is gonna hopefully be broadly applicable
to other use cases as well for policy in
the policy world like a lot of people
are really obsessed right now with being
data-driven but what does that actually
mean in practice and why is Jada a key
ingredient here I think probably you all
have a different I have like a million
different reasons that you could say but
for me I think it's important to convey
the reality of the data world when data
is competing with a lot of other things
in the minds of policymakers and
decision makers so one of the examples I
really love is how many days has it been
since you saw an article on Millennials
for me it's probably less than 24 hours
whenever you ask me that and they kind
of contradict themselves like
Millennials are moving to cities they
love cities they like flexible work
hours they like small kitchens
apparently according to one article you
know like there are so many different
articles based on maybe five people's
experiences or interviews with two
people and everyone wants to get in
front of water Millennials
references so this is actually an issue
because if in my office we're trying to
plan for the next 20 years of what DC
will look like and if you're trying to
design a city design services to a group
of people that you think are taking over
the city and have vastly different
preferences in you do then that's going
to change your decisions about what you
want the city to look like but in
reality actually and I think this is a
great example of data journalism in
reality the Millennials moving to cities
phenomenon is one that's really
restricted to college-educated people in
this age bracket and actually rural and
suburban areas are more popular for
populations of Millennials currently and
this stage is a little old but the same
conclusions carry through and in DC
we're trying to do a little quick it
data journalism to to counteract those
pieces of anecdotal evidence that
policymakers have to filter through
their brains and actually in DC the age
group of 20 to 34 year olds yeah the
population is growing but it's growing
at a slower rate than it was a few years
ago and I just saw everything the adult
population is growing in DC so maybe
looking into that more will give us a
better idea all right what's actually
happening here and how should we really
be designing the city and what should I
play Whitey's be so for me data is
really an antidote to the anecdotes and
a balance not a not a counter-argument
but at least a balance to qualitative
evidence and a dashboard I think is one
answer for getting data into the hands
of people who need it regularly and to
build a story and a narrative around
what the data is actually saying I
almost named this presentation
stop making dashboards because I do
understand
that they are overused and overhyped but
I I'll walk through I think the
principles that make a dashboard
appropriate and useful I just do want to
pull the room quickly how many of you
all have made what you would call a data
dashboard cool you should you should
have gone to a different presentation
you like know everything how many of you
regularly use a data dashboard that
someone else made - cool I'm sorry
everyone else no one's using your
dashboard and that's no that's what I
found - honestly I'll get to that a bit
later though so running through those
principles that I've kind of distilled
from my experience with them
number one consistency in a dashboard I
think the purpose at least for me of
making dashboards of having a group of
data visualizations next together next
to each other is to look at the changes
and comparisons over time because I'm
updating them frequently and to look at
changes you need to be able to notice
between day one and day two what has
changed in the data right and if you
have a changing format an inconsistent
style it's harder to see those changes
there's more cognitive load in the
beginning like what am I looking at it
distracts from what's changing I would
also advocate only trying to show one
conclusion at a time in each building
block of your dashboard I think you can
achieve a certain degree of useful
complexity within the whole page let's
say but if you have a few visualizations
on a page just show one thing in each of
them presumably also you've put these
data points together because they add
layers of complexity and meaning to each
other that's why they're not standing
alone so I think it's also important
obviously to keep colors and formats
similar and consistent across the
dashboard so if blue means DC in one
chart it means DC in every single chart
so that
or doesn't have to again have that
cognitive effort go into alright what am
I seeing that blue I assume is do you
see because I saw a blue is do you see
earlier just keeping the effort on the
viewer very low that way they can spend
more time actually thinking about the
conclusions of your data number two I
would say a dashboard has to include the
right data which right but this is
really key
I want the dashboard to tell a story to
tell a narrative that I think is
interesting and I want to curate the
data so that the right conclusions are
reached this was kind of what Department
of Commerce guy was talking about
earlier so if I want to show the change
over time I show percentage change in
the time series if personal income in DC
went up from 49 billion to 51 billion
last quarter I don't care that doesn't
mean anything to me
a difference of two billion dollars like
that's huge but how huge is it is that
big is it good
instead I'd show the growth rate
compared to the u.s. because we're more
interested actually in whether were
sustaining a high growth rate of income
in DC or comparing it to population so
that we can see the per capita growth in
income those are questions that I'm more
interested in if I want people to
understand and be surprised about say
the level of affordable housing that's
being created in DC I'll give comparison
points for context compared to other
cities of other states
I want a non-expert
to come to the right conclusions
immediately so a label thing it's in a
lot of graphs today and obviously this
is not knocking anyone else because
they're being used for different things
with no labels on the axes like I don't
know what that graph says and neither
what anyone else is just looking at it
for the first time it does take an
incredibly long amount of time at the
beginning to choose and carry the right
data
and the right way to present it and then
one last thing I think there's a really
hard temptation to fight to put
the dashboard data that is easily
accessible or data that updates
frequently because if your data updates
frequently you feel like you're
providing a better service you're
providing a real-time look into this
data and you feel useful you have more
to say about stuff it's a good feeling
but then there's kind of a pitfall of
turning into the drunk guy you see on
the sidewalk looking for his keys you
know that story you come up you fight
you find this guy shuffling around the
sidewalk at midnight say what are you
doing he goes I'm looking for my keys
you say oh did you lose them here it's
like now I got why are you looking here
it's like well this is where the light
is so don't just use data that's where
the light is use data that answers the
problem that questions you actually want
answered and then into more how you use
and curate the data like I was saying
it's helpful to start by answering kind
of the audience's fa Q's not necessarily
so that they can go there it's like a
one-stop shop to find the answers but
also for yourself to be able to answer
them more easily have that data right
there for you and then lastly it's not I
don't think a dashboard should be a
substitute for deep analysis it's not
going to show every answer every time to
any data question you're gonna have or a
question about the economy in my case I
think it's more of an invitation to
think of more questions I think of
better questions about when you see
changes that are worrisome and then I'm
trying to that kind of hits on my early
earlier point about not getting too
complicated with what you're showing
show kind of the bare minimum for the
quick understanding and then deep dives
elsewhere you know so then I want to
talk about also who dashboards are for
and if building off of the class
and I asked over the room and then that
feeling of being useful to when you're
making a dashboard thinking about the
audience is one of the most important
things for me because my job isn't just
to monitor data or use data but it's
it's to get the right facts into the
right people's hands at the right time
too so thinking about how people
interact with data and visualizations
and what I'm saying is really the key I
think for the audience a dashboard is
useful for two things for one initial
context setting so the first time you
see the dashboard you know like huh okay
I didn't know that so for example does
anyone want to guess what the current
unemployment rate and do you see it 10
all right seven in 10 it's actually six
so better news it's good at least you're
right order of magnitude that's good and
in the u.s. right now excuse me it's
it's five percent so we're still higher
than the US but we're lower than we were
January 2015 it was 7.4 percent so I
made some progress but that kind of
thing like those key numbers that as
maybe a policymaker you want to know
right off the bat off the top of your
head it's level setting it's showing you
the the basic order of magnitude of
things that you kind of need to know and
then after that it's a quick reference
because if you know that that's where
you can find the most up-to-date
information on the unemployment rate
because you're giving a speech later
today
then the dashboard is there for a
resource but those I think of the only
uses for the audience for a dashboard
it's really and I think this is kind of
an unpopular opinion the dashboard is
not for the audience it's for me it's
for me to be able to have a standard way
of thinking about the key things that I
need to think about daily or weekly or
monthly and it's for me to be able to
not spend time gathering data but to
have it all there in front of me so I
can get those key points and deliver
them and it's not always going to be in
a lot of people I work with don't think
about things in pictures their policy
people's are lawyers they think about
things in words and I in order to
compete with all these other sources of
data coming in newspaper articles
anecdotes from people they talk to I
needed something to say things three or
four times which it's not enough against
them that's just how you get your story
to stick it's also a dashboard is kind
of a forcing mechanism for me to like
have that library at my fingertips of
data that they want to use and data
that's that's trustworthy daily so kind
of a build at once to have it there to
come back to Emily or other things on to
a kind of resource so that's really for
me the conditions under which a
dashboard works and the kind of
understanding I have going into it that
not a lot of people are going to use it
and play with it the people who would go
into a dashboard and look at how every
piece of data has changed weekly or
monthly they're probably going to go use
the data the raw data themselves that's
kind of their interest so that's the
understanding I have and I'm fine with
it because it's useful for me so I want
to move now into why we're using Python
and this in this case and what kind of
problem my particular dashboard is
solving for economic data there are a
lot of different sources for data and
they update on different calendars and
they're in all sorts of different file
types PDFs
unfortunately forms you have to fill out
three pages or at the forums to get to
an HTML table of data which is if anyone
is from Census Bureau here I would like
word so this is just really time
consuming and energy consuming and my
office before we kind of set up this
function and I will say it's really less
than 10% of my time is like actual data
science type work I also have a lot of
other games to do so Python just made it
quite green easier we were spending a
lot of time answering requests from
journalists let's say for data points
that exist in open data so part of the
part of the reason we created a public
dashboard is for media and journalists
to have kind of a curated list of what
are the most trustworthy data sources
that they can go to themselves and used
to and I think that's most of our
regular user base and here's our
essential workflow right now first
scraping data or accessing data with
Python reshaping it with Python and a
little bit in tableau as well I use
tableau desktop for some reshaping and
then all of the design for the
visualizations we make and I love
tableau if anybody has questions about
it or he'd said I'd love to chat and
then we host it right now on tableau
public which is less than optimal and
then embed the visualizations on a
github pages site and then get feedback
via github and Twitter and I will say
actually we've gotten so many great
suggestions and engagement from people
on Twitter saying I really want to see
this chart and then we've actually put
up then a little data blog of like
really quick heads on economic data in
DC and other types of data in DC because
we've gotten requests on Twitter and
that's kind
the most fun part of my job another way
to do it would be to scrape and reshape
and Python design with d3 and then host
everything on the web - so that's what
we're kind of flirting with moving to as
well I will say I would rather be using
tableau server because then the whole
process would be completely automated
and hands-off for me because tableau
server allows you to schedule data
refreshes and so I wouldn't have to
right now I have to manually push it to
tableau public which is unfortunate but
is the silver lining there is it does
it's another forcing mechanism for me to
look at the data and make sure
everything is good as gold yeah yeah we
have a very we have no data
infrastructure I just save all of my
Python scraped data files into our
network drive and they all live in CSV s
and Excel files we're not using that
much data if we want to be probably not
not the way to do it for sure but that's
what we're doing and it works your name
all right so since every web scraper is
its own little special snowflake I'm not
going to suggest tools to get the same
thing done every time because really you
need to know the data that you're
scraping to write the right scraper but
it is a really good forcing mechanism
and I think I've said that phrase a lot
but it is helpful to build a scraper
because it makes you get to know your
data really well from the beginning and
sometimes the fun part of it is that you
find out things like when I'm scraping
residential building permits from this
Sun
is saying which again if there's anyone
here from census I really apologize this
is the way I'm doing it it's probably
really expensive to you but maybe you'll
put it in an easier format I haven't
done in a few months because they
actually took down the site
maybe it's my I don't know but you'd
find out things like they have
misspelled disturbed of Columbia in the
data and that's why my code was breaking
Census Bureau do you work for census is
it you well again
a word please census bureau so yeah
that's kind of fun but here here are my
little package of tools that i've used a
combination of these and every scraper
I've made and I really only have a dozen
of them because I'm only using maybe a
dozen open data data sources from BLS
Bureau of Economic Analysis Fred the st.
Louis Fed database of economic data it's
great so I'll just go through these
requests of course xlrd reads excel
miles because sometimes data comes in
just an excel download from the web and
I need to go in and reshape it XLS X
writer writes Excel files so does open
pixel it's a little more powerful though
and it plays with panda as well pandas
of course does everything I use it
mostly for be shaping because I'm doing
my visuals in tableau and it's really
it's really a simple task that I need
Python for is just getting getting the
data and reshaping it on the other side
JSON various api's that government
agencies have developed various wrappers
make it a lot easier like I mentioned
the Fed API wrapper and then config
parser because I
but most if not all of my scrapers
online to hide my bi keys beautifulsoup
for parsing HTML luckily I don't do a
lot of that because that's more annoying
and in that Census Bureau example I
showed the difficulty there was you have
to fill in a form for every month of
data you want actually not you have to
fill in three forms on two different web
pages and then the third gives you the
data in it and an HTML table so I had to
stumbled upon mechanize to emulate a
browser so that I could fill in those
forms ad choices to one of the forms
because Washington DC was missing and
then scrape the data that that came from
a totally unrelated talk at the DC hack
Intel so I will say in addition to just
like listening to other people talk
about Python another great tool that is
actually common to all the scrapers that
I've made is this thing but you may have
heard of that's only common to all all
of these and then another note about
scraping incrementally versus pulling
down the data all the data that I need
every time I do feel a little bit bad
that for a lot of them I'm pulling all
the data over but not that bad because
economic data at least is frequently
revised and not just the previous month
like frequently found it to be incorrect
or they changed the model for months
quarters years back in the past so this
this chart here you're looking at the
percent change and personal income in DC
and two weeks ago it looked like that
top chart and then one week ago they
reminded a really far back so I would
have if I were scraping just at the next
stage of data I would have had a
weird jump in q2 2016 but fortunately
I'm spending more of their resources and
getting all the data every time just
something to consider it's also easier
for me then that's great
and I'm just gonna quickly demo what
product we've built here it's really
just kind of an interpretive layer on
top of okay that's not gonna work an
interpretive layer on top of data that's
out there open anybody can use but not
everyone wants to here we go so another
thing is it doesn't look like a
government site well I hope not because
the rest of our government sites look
like our own sites I think an important
thing for interpreting the data is
having a lot of white space so really
quick stats here I will show this chart
here average hourly wages of private
sector jobs in DC starting in kind of
mid 2015 started seeing the wages going
down add the peak or I guess the trough
of this weird phase here wages were down
10 percent year-over-year which is
really big and we were pretty confused
about what was going on and how long
this would last and the key here I think
going back to some other points I made
earlier is that that's didn't answer any
questions about why this was happening
like that's not the purpose of the
dashboard it led us to a tell people a
lot it took me maybe five months of
saying wages are down wages are down
wages are down every week until
someone's like
why what's going on here do you would
you have any about this is why I did
because I had been looking at it and
formulating hypotheses and using other
data editor to answer those questions
turns out it kind of turned around
lately
this spring let's go in the other
direction but GC was the only city
besides some really energy dependent
cities in Texas where this was happening
so it was it was pretty worrisome turns
out the most likely hypothesis and we
had a few economists swing in on this
but not really do an in-depth look is
that we added a lot of hourly low in
shops in DC restaurant jobs service
industry jobs which is actually good
news that part of our economy is growing
and it was just kind of bring me down
the average a bit so that was something
we were less worried about after we were
able to look into a few possibilities
and just to do a quick intro here none
of this is really related to anything
I'm web scraping because it's internal
data on what affordable housing we're
creating in the district as you may know
it's a very expensive city and we're
never gonna have enough affordable
housing but we're actually as a city
doing way more investment in affordable
housing than any other city in the
country or any state actually then
Florida
Florida's only state that has a larger
housing trust fund than we do but we
were able to get our data that we are
producing with a lot of other agencies
and put it out for the first time to the
public here and instead of putting out
just rows and rows of project data we
did some visuals which I think people
connected with a lot more certainly
journalists connected with more and one
of the good things about using tableau
is this can be shared and embedded
anywhere else and greater Greater
Washington recently embedded this chart
in one of their articles and so the
article will update as we update the
data here which i think is pretty cool
such as motor explore here and I have
here we started also a little data blog
did you like not really in-depth
analyses but quick hits right here's
some data here's what it says here's
what's interesting about it and here's
an open invitation for any of you all if
you're working with data on DC please
get in touch with me so you can do a
little guest post on our blog if you'd
like to we've had some folks from the
civic hacking community do guest posts
folks from other DC agencies who are
working with data that you might not
always get to see because it's not
public they've done some guest posts and
down here you can subscribe for updates
if you want or receive emails with our
little data blog posts and also if
you're a UX ER I would like to talk
because I know this website isn't laid
out or as user friendly as it could be
because I'm not a UX ER and since my
team is me no one else's either in my
office so if you want to provide some
public service let's talk all right any
questions
there are a few sources for housing
prices we use Zillow data which is not
perfect but has pretty good coverage in
urban areas if you're looking for
housing prices in like rural Montana I
would say don't use Zillow but probably
there's not a lot of products for you
anyway another another housing index
would be CoreLogic we also post I think
that Case Shiller index which is a
little bit slower than others but pretty
rigorous as well and then the FHFA or
Fannie or Freddie I forget which of
those entities also just recently came
out with a new or improvements to their
housing price index which is based only
on sales of houses which get Fannie or
Freddie looks so it's a really robust
data set that has that limitation to
Zillow obviously tries to compute prices
for all homes not just recent sales and
I think depending on what you want the
what coverage and universe you want you
want to look into whether the housing
price index that you're using is a
repeat sales index only using homes
which have data points from sales
recently and like tracking the same
homes or a oh my gosh I'm going to
forget the name of it but a different
model that uses the characteristics of
the homes and doesn't necessarily track
the same house over time but computes
value from homes with similar
characteristics selling
some are not free because these
companies have kind of cornered the
public records markets to provide them
as home price indices basically like
CoreLogic they publish their index in
PDFs which are really secure so if you
want if you have an intern your likes
typing you could get that the
case-shiller is available on Fred and oh
yeah the reason we're not posting that
is because everything on our site is
open licensed but as some PE owns the
Case Shiller index and they haven't
gotten back to me about allowing me to
post it so some are somewhere Zillow
says they are yeah yeah
uh try not to use it even if I need to
tabula is a good tool it's pretty manual
still itself if anybody has a great
solution to making structured data out
of machine readable PDFs please let me
know because I would love to sorry
some of them are some of them aren't
great that's true it's Jim
alright thanks thanks thanks room
yeah we've been slowly turning some of
our visualizations into hand-coded d3
ones it's slow because like I said this
is really less than 10% of our time and
were two-ish person team so if you know
anyone who is an intern and once to do
t3 I love that yeah it's more of just
like a resource and expertise kind of
thing for us at this at this point yeah
yeah actually when we set up the site we
were pretty clear that we were gonna be
conclusion agnostic about what we post
so I have a communications director who
gets the little antsy sometimes but I
have to remind him like this is what
that you agreed to in the beginning and
I will say there's kind of a higher
hurdle for things that we would posts
that have like negative conclusions on
do you see not because not because we
have a hesitancy to post them but more
because we want to know what underlying
causes there are more for those kinds of
things so we'll spend more time and duty
for dives on those rather than just
posting them and be like what wait we
saw this thing what's going on you know
we care about actually what we're
putting out and what conclusions are
reaching so that's that's maybe the only
the only political consequence
so this this page is lives on github and
github pages and I will say I forgot to
mention it was based on the cfpb's dr.
template and then tableau provides embed
codes to just put an iframe in the page
and that's that's a magic okay that's
good yeah cuz I would really love to
have some structured data that is from a
lot of PDF forms that are the same thank
you PDF query yep
I use the ACS API it's really difficult
to find the exact data point you're
looking for because that page there like
data dictionary so many rows that it
often crashes my Google Chrome it's just
so many rows but I'd say look up what
you what data you need in the American
FactFinder and then just find those data
points that's really the biggest the
biggest hurdle there but I also have
some scrapers online if you would like
to see them they're my github thank you
thanks for having me